the horror of sarah everard's final
hours prompted an outpouring of grief
but it was the fact that the man
responsible was a serving police officer
which added to the disbelief at her fate
wayne cousins pretended to be on duty
when he kidnapped the 33 year old before
raping and then murdering her earlier
this year
his case is extreme but he's not alone
in abusing a position of trust for
sexual gain
and the number of cases being reported
has soared
the abuse of position for a sexual
purpose currently makes up nearly 60
percent of investigations by the
independent office for police conduct
from 2018 to 2021 66 officers and
members of police staff faced
disciplinary proceedings as a result
42 of those in the past year
in 63 cases misconduct was proven
with six people convicted of crimes
those figures have gone up because it's
become a mandatory referral so people
have to refer it to us now but we would
hope that also it reflects a increased
awareness
where we are seeing fellow officers for
example reporting people that they
believe might be doing that and those
are being referred to us as well
it hasn't reassured former animal rights
activist jessica who was unaware her
partner of a year back in the 90s was an
undercover officer if they break the law
then surely there should be you know
absolute zero
tolerance policy
and you know it needs again it's that
it's the transparency you know far too
many police officers
that have done something wrong you know
it's all swept under the carpet you know
there's the the sort of the policy of
you know the old boys club
the organizers of the vigil held after
sarah everard's murder also want more to
be done
if we are only measuring instances of
harassment and violence we're missing
all of the warning signs of misogyny
this report uh from the iopc talks about
um
sexual offences uh where an officer
abuses their power well that's the worst
case scenario before that point that
officer has probably
done things which make women
uncomfortable when cousin's nickname was
the rapist the iopc is clear that those
who abuse their position for sexual gain
will be found out
but there's work to be done to rebuild
trust in those whose roles should be to
protect
emma birchley sky news